[Musique]
José Legault Madeleine blémorin Michel
David bonsoir bonsoir ce matin je le
disais en d'entrée de jeu au début de
l'émission entre autres sur la Une de la
presse on voyait madame guillebois à
Paris qui étudie le système de métro
tout va bien les ministres des
Transports c'est son rôle mais là il y a
une crise à gérer à Montréal et là on
est vraiment en communication 101 en
fait j'ai hâte de vous entendre et dit
j'imagine à son entourage on peut pas
commencer à envoyer des photos demain
après-demain de d'Europe je reviens au
pays tout de suite même si elle ne gère
pas la SAC José opération donc de
communication politique
oui opération visibilité
opération il y a une ministre en
contrôle parce que l'autre ministre
en amont ericare ministre des Numériques
on le voit pas on le voit pas on
l'entend pas donc ça laisse tout le
terrain finalement politique j'entends
bien à Madame Guilbault mais connaissant
son mode opéradi qu'elle soit ici ou non
c'est sûr qu'elle est sur le dossier au
téléphone depuis le début avec Denis
marcelet le PDG de la SAQ mais
politiquement c'était son retour est
nécessaire ouais Madeleine c'est ça de
même si elle ne prenne qui gère les
détails de la crise les perceptions
c'est important et la présence de dire
on n'est pas très loin du feu c'est
important aussi les apparences et se
montrer sensible aussi c'est drôle tout
à l'heure monsieur marcelet dans votre
entrevue Patrice disait à la toute fin
comme s'il voulait insister là-dessus
vous savez on n'est pas insensible à ce
qui se passe
et pour le montrer madame Guilbaud
devait être sur place de vraiment
montrer que elle comprend qu'un problème
qu'il faut le régler ça se règle le
repas d'ici demain matin là le
changement au numérique a créé un goulot
d'étranglement ça crée des retards il y
a du rattrapage à faire il y a des
problèmes qu'on avait pas anticipé dans
le changement de système donc tout ça va
pas se régler d'ici demain matin la
semaine dernière à la SAQ on nous disait
que ça serait fin avril avant que ça
soit réglé donc imaginez la période de
frustration elle va durer longtemps donc
il faut pas donner la perception dès le
début que la ministre n'est pas sur
place que la ministre n'est pas
préoccupé par la situation donc revenir
c'était la bonne décision j'imagine
Michel qu'elle appelle assez souvent je
m'harcelais qui vous doit avoir le
numéro de la cabinet de la ministre qui
arrive souvent Michel ouais ben madame
Guilbaud à la réputation d'être assez
contrôlante merci et je doute pas que ça
travail et l'expérience de ce genre de
contrôle de crise souvenez-vous quand
elle était à sécurité publique quand il
y avait des inondations c'était pas long
qu'on l'a retrouvé sur les lieux avec
ses bottes alors non je pense que c'est
une gestion de crise tout à fait
classique
la chance que le gouvernement a c'est
que il y a pas de déchéance électorale à
court terme on peut facilement penser
que dans quelques mois tout ça va de
l'histoire ancienne mais pour le moment
c'est certainement avoir à ça et
je pense que quand le syndicat dit on
les on leur avait dit
la tendance d'un gouvernement c'est
toujours de précipiter les choses qui
risquent de les faire bien paraître mais
quand ton manque notre coup ça donne ça
et il y a des gens oui allez-y José
il reste que sur le plan politique
monsieur la raison bon il y aura pas de
coûts politiques à payer le gouvernement
le bruit tellement populaire domine
tellement dans les sondages mais elle
reste pas moins que pour un gouvernement
qui s'est moqué beaucoup du gouvernement
Trudeau dans le gaz du dossier des
passeports
les c'est trop perduré cette crise là
parce que ça en est une ce serait quand
même aussi difficile à justifier une
autre chose c'est que ce virage ce méga
virage numérique là encore une fois oui
ericaire ont peut-être on va mettre sa
photo sur une pinte de lait bientôt
c'est faudra voir aussi est-ce que il y
a des problèmes qui vont se mettre à
apparaître ailleurs dans le gouvernement
ce qu'il y aura d'autres programmes où
il y a eu une virage numérique peut-être
moins bien préparée je sais pas mais
pour le mais le gouvernement n'aurait
pas besoin que ça se répercute dans
d'autres départements ou d'autres
ministères ou d'autres organismes et
d'ailleurs ceux qui étaient pas avec
nous en début d'émission
désolé je lui posais la question est-ce
qu'il va avoir une période de grâce pour
les permis de conduire les
renouvellements etc il me dit qu'ils
sont à quelques jours de l'annoncer là
c'est j'ai bien compris et aussi les
contraventions que les gens auront reçu
et il m'a confirmé qu'il y en a eu
seront remboursés comme un gros point
d'interrogation parce ceux qui sont ont
déjà contestés savent que ça peut être
long et compliqué mais avoir on attend
des précisions sur ces deux
avenues là d'apaisement pour les
citoyens qui est un minimum vraiment
il me semble aussi la Chine
hier
nous nous attendions le point de presse
de Monsieur oui un peu en retard de
Monsieur Trudeau il annoncé un certain
nombre de choses on va vous montrer un
tableau ceux qui ont pas suivi ça
aujourd'hui mais ça a été très rapporté
donc une enquête mais pas publique une
enquête du Comité de la sécurité
nationale ça existe déjà ce comité là
les députés qui ont
eu qui ont d'un seuil de sécurité plus
élevée donc ils peuvent entendre des
secrets sans les rapporter rapporteur
spécial indépendants qui sera nommé pour
juger
de ces travaux là et de conseiller le
gouvernement Madeleine si j'ai bien
compris sur la propos peut-être d'une
enquête plus publique après puis au
registre public des agents étrangers sur
l'Australie fait ça on a annoncé alors
je fais entendre avant de vous donner la
parole l'opposition aujourd'hui qui
était évidemment pas satisfaite et on
revient
nous avons une revendiquer
une enquête publique et indépendante
public et indépendant public et
indépendance celles sont des deux choses
qui faut avoir dans n'importe quel
enquête que faites juste introdo
exactement le contraire je suis d'accord
à la condition que le mandat soit
d'emblée que l'enquête soit public et
qui soit désigné par le Parlement
sinon on n'est pas d'accord avec ça ou
un autre mot
c'est pourquoi on dit que la déclaration
ou les étapes suggérées par le premier
essai sont des petits pas et on va voir
les résultats
nous sommes ouverts à toute suggestions
que les parties de position vont nous
partager en termes de non qualifiés
éminent et indépendant qui pourraient
aller de l'avant et nous allons nous
assurer que la personne choisie soit la
bonne personne non seulement pour
évaluer le travail qui est en train de
faire et qui doit encore être fait mais
aussi pour donner confiance au Canadiens
que ça va être fait de façon
indépendante irigoureuse
ça c'était aujourd'hui monsieur Trudeau
qui a été questionné là-dessus Madeleine
expliquez-nous le contexte de cette
annonce parfois ce que c'était précipité
embrouillé ce qui nous manquait des
détails vous allez me dire précipiter
non ça fait longtemps en fait que le
gouvernement Trudeau se fait talonner
par l'opposition qui réclame une enquête
publique sur les allégations d'ingérence
de la Chine dans les élections de 2019
et de 2021 il y a encore des zones
d'ombre Patrice en 2019 2021 il y aurait
eu donc de l'ingérence chinoise qui
n'aurait pas eu d'incidence sur le
résultat global des élections donc les
libéraux auraient bel et bien gagné de
façon juste est-ce que dans certains
côtés l'ingérence chinoise aurait fait
en sorte que un candidat aurait pu
gagner ou perdre à cause de ça ça il
reste encore un peu de zones d'ombre là
dessus et que sa ville gouvernement
est-ce que il y a eu des breffages
techniques et qu'est-ce qui le sud quand
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait avec ces
informations là donc il y a encore il y
a encore des questions qui se posent
donc l'opposition réclamait une enquête
publique indépendante pour faire la
lumière là-dessus et redonner confiance
dans notre système électoral Justin
Trudeau n'était pas chaud du tout à
l'idée d'une enquête publique on
comprend que quand on est gouvernement
on a pas nécessairement intérêt à donner
tout le pouvoir à un juge qui pose des
questions donc c'est peut-être un peu
délicat politiquement d'avoir une
enquête publique il a coupé la poire en
deux il a dit je vais vous annoncer un
rapporteur spécial quelqu'un qui va
déterminer si oui ou non il y aura en
quête donc il Pelt par en avant on ne
sait pas qui sera ce rapporteur
on ne sait pas qui donc l'opposition dit
les bloquistes entre autres disent si ce
sont les libéraux qui nomment ce
rapporteur spécial ce conseiller spécial
qui va nous garantir que ce sera pas
quelqu'un qui est qui
plaider pour les libéraux donc vous
voyez on a eu une réponse qui était pas
une réponse satisfaisante du tout de la
part de qui n'était pas satisfait du
tout l'opposition puisque c'est pas ce
qu'elle demande Michel est-ce que
sur sur l'annonce hier mais aussi de
façon plus globale est-ce qu'une enquête
publique est possible avec des sujets
comme ceux-là qui sont en partie secrets
ben oui c'est toujours possible de
déterrer ce qui ne tombe pas sous le
coup du secret et c'est je pense qui est
le plus embarrassant pour le
gouvernement parce que les services de
sécurité tout ça vont continuer à
observer le même silence mais il y a des
choses comme par exemple on pourrait
faire comparaître le député libéral
monsieur angle qui était au centre de
tout ça on pourrait faire comparaître
des gens qui ont contribué d'une façon
bizarre disons à diverses activités que
ce soit le fond de
Monsieur Trudeau Trude
tout ce qui est tout ça est en
périphérie du Parti libéral alors il y
avait une enquête publique mais qui
porterait davantage sur disons les
turpitudes du Parti libéral que sur le
fond de la chose alors on peut
comprendre que les libéraux sont pas du
tout intéressés à ça et moi je vois la
nomination de cette rapporteur spécial
indépendant c'est cette nouvelle bébé là
dans le dans la panoplie des enquêtes je
vois ça comme une façon de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait pas d'enquête c'est à
dire que là je pense que le procureur a
fait le rapporteur va finir par dire ben
non finalement c'est pas nécessaire pour
X
raison si les crédits auprès de la
population les gens vont dire bon
peut-être que et le temps va s'être
écoulé la lassitude va peut-être
s'emparer des gens qui vont passer à
autre chose alors je vois ça plus comme
une tentative de Monsieur Trudeau de
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas en bout
de ligne d'enquête qu'une volonté de
faire vraiment de la lumière José
la plus précieuse c'est le temps
n'est-ce pas bon il finit éventuellement
par jouer contre un gouvernement mais il
peut quand même il peut quand même en
profiter pendant une certaine période je
pense que c'est Jack meeting qui devient
résumé c'est vraiment la stratégie des
petits pas qu'on pourrait appeler et
c'est quand même assez habile oui ça ne
satisfait pas les oppositions bien
entendu mais je me suis Trudeau s'achète
du temps et là la clé va être qui va
être se rapporter là homme ou femme
écoutez c'est une perle rare la commande
les attentes sont dans le plafond donc
il va falloir que ce soit une personne
hyper compétente dans le domaine hyper
indépendante sur le plan politique qui
fasse pas l'unanimité mais au moins
consensus
bonne chance ça se trouve pas dans les
petits annonces ça donc ça c'est ça
c'est l'obstacle comme Monsieur Trudeau
à moins qu'il est quelqu'un déjà en tête
mais c'est clair que ce sera une perle
rare et c'est intéressant ce que vous
dites parce que si hier Madeleine il est
arrivé avec un nom
qui allait résonner et les gens ah oui
on peut avoir confiance mais comme dit
José c'est pas facile à trouver et
peut-être qu'il n'a pas reçu de réponse
positive d'un certain nombre de
personnes ouais je sais pas s'il est en
train d'éplucher des CV en ce moment
mais effectivement la tâche est énorme
idéalement ce serait quelqu'un de
bilingue vraiment loin des libéraux faut
pas recommencer l'épisode Maurice
frozenberg dont Michel faisait allusion
tout à l'heure celui qui était
anciennement PDG de la Fondation Trudeau
qui avait accepté un don qui était
associé à la Chine donc voyez-vous il a
été critiqué pour ça et les libéraux ont
pas vraiment un bilan reluisant au
chapitre des nominations pensées par
exemple récemment il y avait
cette conseillère qui devait conseiller
le gouvernement sur la lutte contre
l'islamophobie et qui a fait elle-même
controverse donc Justin Trudeau pourrait
peut-être avoir avantage à consulter les
parties d'opposition à tout réessayer de
calmer le jeu sur la nomination de
rapporteur est-elle toujours un poste
mais je veux pas vous lancer là-dessus
parce que j'ai oui bien sûr ok
c'est intéressant parce que au lendemain
de l'élection le chef conservateur Éric
Duhem disait à cette antenne il dit oui
moi dès qu'il va avoir un peu de
mouvement dans le caucus de la CAQ
l'invitation restera va partir puis je
veux aller débaucher quelqu'un voici que
Marie-Louise Tardy
député de la violette Saint-Maurice
se retire du cocu de la CAQ parce que
elle est sous enquête parce qu'elle
aurait menacé dans le cas d'une cause
devant les petites créances une ancienne
employée en disant ça va être ton tour
bientôt on a la citation là je sais pas
tout à fait exact que j'ai dit mais
c'est bon on va on va embarquer sur ton
cas voilà ce qu'elle a dit Michel David
occasion en ordre Dumaine je pense qu'il
va attendre de voir ce qui va arriver
avec Madame tardif c'est certain que je
pense que il devrait attendre mais je
pense pas que ça traîne tellement
longtemps alors cette histoire-là je
pense que ça va
s'éclaircir assez vite mais
je sais pas si Madame tardif est
intéressée c'est loin d'être certain
mais je suis pas convaincu que ça serait
la meilleure porte-parole pour monsieur
John vous allez me dire que c'est mieux
que pas de porte-parole du tout là
je vais vous dire ça
je comprends son désir ardent d'entrer à
l'Assemblée nationale on voit ses
intentions de vote là qui qui
disparaissent de moi en moi mais
j'attendrai à sa place
oui parce que ça pourrait être un cadeau
empoisonné ça c'est sûr et certain donc
c'est pour l'opportunisme en politique
l'homme encore
faut-il aller à la chasse pour quelque
chose qui en vaut la peine donc oui je
pense que je pense qu'il va attendre et
non c'est pas ce serait vraiment
prématuré que tu fais ça peut toujours
aller manger avec la s'il veut même mais
pour dire que le frère aussi de madame
tartif avait été candidat pour le parti
oui
voilà mais bon ce coup-ci semble être
complexe c'est bon
réponse à tout ça mais Madeleine je
faisais des blagues mais pour Monsieur
dum
si jamais il réussit à débaucher un ou
une députée ça change la donne dans le
dans le jeu de la santé parce
qu'effectivement tout d'un coup il a un
pied à l'Assemblée nationale alors qu'en
ce moment il n'en a pas donc Madame
Tardy n'est pas nécessairement une
porte-parole des rituels c'est une porte
d'entrée pour l'Assemblée nationale donc
Éric dum j'ai bien l'impression moi
qu'il serait content d'avoir cette porte
d'entrée là et c'est peut-être pas pour
rien aussi que la CAC fait va pas
nécessairement la laisser aller si
facilement madame Tardy en 89 et 90
députés il y a pas une énorme différence
pour la CAQ sauf qu'il y a cette
différence plus importante si tout d'un
coup est rituel a une députée dans son
caucus et d'ailleurs elle est suspendue
elle n'est pas exclue en fait
théorie des petits pas de Jack meeting
encore une fois dans ce cas-ci merci
beaucoup à vous trois bonne soirée au
revoir à très bientôt bonsoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI